now that we've got bare metal servers
for vpc live in the ibm cloud i'm going
to take you through a quick intro and
demo of this exciting offering ibm cloud
bare metal servers for vpc using intel
xeon processors are helping our clients
land large workloads into a faster and
more scalable environment with all the
network connectivity benefits that you
would expect in a virtual private cloud
hi i'm amarte pearson a senior technical
staff member with ibm cloud and the lead
architect for vpc bare metal
infrastructure so what is a bare metal
server for vpc think of it like a
virtual server except that it gives you
the entire physical machine delivering
all the benefits that you would expect
of bare metal such as enabling you to
leverage your own hypervisor or any
specialized workload all inside of the
software defined vpc network
bare metal built-in vpc is a major
quality of life improvement with fast
provisioning per hour billing and
perhaps most importantly full
integration with the vpc network
native to vpc bare metal is now capable
of 100 gigabits of network throughput
providing exceptional speed vpc network
constructs such as security groups
custom routes load balancers they're all
fully supported
compared to our classic bare metal
offering bare metal for vpc brings
greater throughput scalability and the
performance expected in a cloud
environment let's take you through the
ordering experience and show you how to
order a bare metal server and do
something super simple like attach a
floating ip let's get started
first i need to log into the ibm cloud
console for new users a paygo account is
required to access most infrastructure
services including bare metal for vpc
you'll see a new bare metal servers for
vpc tile in the catalog we'll go ahead
and select that you'll find that under
the services compute section of the
catalog
for vpc users this should feel familiar
when compared with virtual servers here
we can name our server select a resource
group data center location operating
system select our server profile and
customize our network options
let's dive into the profiles
our servers feature intel xeon
processors including two cpu and four
cpu profiles in various memory and
secondary local drive configurations
here i've chosen a profile with 96 cores
768 gigabytes of ram and 16 3.2 terabyte
nvme drives
these servers are ideal for high-end
performance workloads because of their
all-flash storage and high intel cpu
core count perfect for slicing up into a
lot of chunks whether it's virtual
machines or containers
the secondary local drives are all nvme
allowing you to get some truly amazing i
o performance
i also like that it's optimized for
certified workloads and software
solutions and flexible enough for
workloads such as openshift vmware and
sap
once your selections are to your liking
you can click create on the right hand
side and wait for the provisioning to
complete
this typically takes about 10 minutes to
complete in comparison to bare metal in
our classic infrastructure which varies
between two and four hours depending on
the complexity of your config
in vpc we're going to save a lot of time
once we've created the server you'll see
a list of your existing servers with the
new server in pending state
you'll notice that we're in the vpc
section of the customer portal in the
compute bare metal servers subsection
instead of waiting for the server to
finish deploying let's click on a server
i deployed earlier and see detailed
information about the host
here you'll find all the details about
your server and the ability to modify
things such as the name or add
additional network interfaces
you'll notice how similar this is to
virtual servers and that's intentional
there's an actions menu at the top which
allows you to power on or off or restart
the server as well as launch a graphical
or serial console to the bare metal
server the graphical console allows you
to interact with the server before it's
even powered on
the network interfaces have a few more
capabilities compared to virtual servers
such as the ability to choose an
interface type but otherwise should be
very familiar to virtual server users
so i promised i'd show you how to attach
a floating ip after we created the bare
metal server
to do so we'll simply edit any interface
on which we want to add a floating ip
we'll select an existing or create a new
ip and hit save
we can now use that public floating ip
immediately
in this case i'll simply point to that
ip in my browser and we'll see a login
screen for vmware esxi which is the
operating system image that we chose
when creating the server
with our virtual private cloud
networking as a foundation our new bare
metal servers fit in perfectly with the
rest of your cloud infrastructure you
can worry less by reducing complexity in
your network design rapid scaling and
hourly billing with bare metal for vpc
also means that you aren't trading off
between scale out speed and compute
performance
now that you've seen how easy it is sign
up and try bare metal for vpc today
if you have any questions please leave a
comment below if you enjoyed the content
please like and subscribe for more
videos